in this video we actually see how we can
perform sequence classification in a
linear chain conditional random field so
so far what we've seen is how we could
compute the probability the joint
probability of a whole sequence of
labels given an input sequence so we've
seen how we could compute in particular
this nasty partition function using
dynamic programming and we are also
seeing how we could compute marginal
probabilities for instance the marginal
probabilities of a label like given
position K given the full sequence and
again performing this computation
required the same dynamic program that
we can use for computing the partition
function or would compute these log
alpha and log beta tables and use them
in the computation of the marginal
probability now here what we'll see is
how we can actually perform
classification so if I give you a
sequence of inputs now I ask you to
provide with provide me a sequence of
labels that you think is a good
prediction for the sequence of the
actual true sequence of labels that that
say a human or an expert would have
predicted so there are two options here
so we'll see two different procedures
for performing that prediction the first
is perhaps the simplest what we do is
that for each position K we compute the
marginal P of YK given the sequence so
we compute the probability for any
potential label YK
of it being the true K of label in the
sequence and then as our prediction we
just say that in our predicted sequence
the label for the gift prediction the
key of the position is going to be the
label that has the highest marginal
probability now so this is very similar
to how for a neural network that would
take just a single input so not in the
sequence prediction setting we would
just feed the input to the neural net it
would produce
a output distribution for what the true
label would be for the given input and
we just take the label with the highest
probability now we can actually show
that this procedure for constructing a
prediction sequence so a sequence of
labels that we would provide as an
answer is corresponds to the prediction
that minimizes the sum of classification
errors over the whole sequence if we
assume that our linear conditional
random field so our model is actually
the true model is the true distribution
that produced the sequence labels in our
data set so we actually know this gives
some justification for using that
procedure and because this is an
interesting concept actually will
actually do the demonstration for why
maximizing for each position the
marginal distribution actually
corresponds to finding this minimizing
sequence of the sum of classification
error if we assume our model is the true
distribution so what we want to do is I
find the expression for what is the
predicted sequence Y star that minimizes
in expectation so I should say this is
the minimization in expectation
according to our model of the sum of the
classification error for each position
so we have the sum of the identity
function of whether the true labeled
according to our model YK so it's true
label in the sense that it's the label
that based on the distribution of our
model is different from the predicted
label at position K so Y star K so want
to minimize in expectation that's some
of classification error per position so
here I'm just writing explicitly what
this expectation here is it's the nested
sum over the first label up to the last
label of the sum of parrell per position
classification error weighted by the
probability according to my model that I
would observe this
of labels why so these YK is here hey
I'm writing the fact that the
minimization overall sequences y star is
equivalent to performing that mutation
it's the same as performing minimization
sequentially over the first label until
the last label so it's this minimization
over all sequences is the same as these
nested minimization over first seek
first position second position until the
last position now here what I'm doing is
that I'm going to take that first I'm
going to introduce this here which
allows me to just remove this
parenthesis and I'm going to change the
order of the sums so I'm going to
actually sum first over the position K
and then sum over the value of the first
label up to the last label so that's why
I have K here then first label up to the
last label okay so that that's all I've
done introduce this here and then change
the order of the sums of the nested
sounds now I notice that this term here
only depends on the value of YK for the
position K that's indexed here so I can
actually this is a constant with respect
to y 1y K minus 1 YK plus 1 up to so
there should be two three dots here up
to the last label so I can actually push
this here up upwards in the nested sums
right in front of the sum over the value
of the K at label and the sequence
position K at which I'm measuring the
error next I notice that this expression
here that's just the marginal P of YK
given the sequence so I've taken the
full joint distribution well conditioned
on the input sequence the junk
distribution over the whole sequence Y
but I'm summing over all the values that
every label can take take except the
label YK
so that's the marginal
P of Y given X next I realized that this
sum here overall position of what is
essentially the expected error for that
position well that's essentially the sum
of the sum over y1 of whether I'm making
an error by predicting Y star 1 x
weighted by the probability of actually
seeing y1 as the first label plus so I
do this this sum over all a K so then
sum up to the sum over Y capital K of
whether I'm making an error by
predicting Y prime Y star capital gay
weighted by the probability that the
true label would actually be Y Capital J
now so I have a sum and minimizing over
the sum for each label well because each
term in the sum actually depends on the
single label well that's the same as
minimizing the first term so with
respect to y 1 and actually I'm sorry Y
star 1 only and and I don't need to
minimize over the other terms because
they are not involved in that expression
plus the minimization with respect to Y
star to up to the so plus up to the
minimization over the last label of this
term here okay so that's because the
minimization over all labels for a term
that depends on only one label is the
same as minimization minimizing over a
single position or a single label and so
now the we notice that let me remove
some ink so we noticed that this
expression here which is the sum of 1 if
y1 is not Y star 1 weighted that by the
probability of observing y1 so that's
the sum of the probability of y 1 for
every case except when y1 is equal to Y
star 1 so in other words so that's the
probability of the first label not being
why star one which is equal to one minus
the probability of the label being Y
star one and so similarly for this term
we also get one minus the probability of
Y star capital K and then finally
performing each minimization minimizing
one minus this term is the same as doing
one minus the maximum of this term so
indeed this is a constant so I can't
minimize it really that the choice of y
star one won't change the value of one
and so I can introduce this here and the
minimization of the negative of
something is the same as minus the
maximization of that something so that's
what I have here so this is equivalent
to this and in particular the argument
the argument here or the arc max is the
arc max here and in other words it's the
sequence where the first label is the
one that maximizes the marginal
probability for the first element in the
sequence and then same thing for the
second label third label up to the last
label which in my prediction should be
the label y star K which maximizes the
marginal probability of the of the label
at the last position at the position
capital K okay so this ends our
demonstration that if I assume the true
labels were generated by my model my
linear conditional random field then if
I wanted to minimize the expected
classification error per position the
right thing to do would actually to be
to produce the sequence of all labels
that maximize the probability of being
observed according to my model for each
position in constructing my prediction
by concatenated all of these sequence
all of these labels so that's the first
option another option would be to do the
equivalent of what we were doing in the
non sequential prediction part that is
out
produced as my sequence output the so
actually this should be a star here I
just produce as the sequence output the
single sequence with the largest
probability the largest joint
probability condition on my input
sequence and so I'll go rapidly over
this but it turns out that much like
we've seen a way of actually summing
over the something like this term the
exponential and exponentiated sum of log
factors we can also perform the
maximization with the dynamic program so
we'll do what we get essentially as a
variant of the Viterbi decoding
algorithm where in the forward pass so
much like in the Alpha dynamic
programming where we for the log alpha
we had locked some expirations
well in the this Viterbi decoding
algorithm we replace those by the
maximization with respect to Y prime K
instead and then we fill the table with
those values and in fact if you think
about it lock some X is actually can be
thought of as a smooth version of the
maximization operation and that's
because because of the exponential
exponential hear the term diet is going
to dominate this sum is going to be the
term that is largest because the
exponential increases very rapidly with
large values of its argument and then
taking the log we go back to the
original scale and so really the term
that's going to dominate this whole term
here is going to be the maximum so so
that's just you know a nice fact to know
about the relationship between the logs
of X and the maximization and but so
yeah so we take the forward pass say in
the diamond program that computes the
log alpha table and which we place
deluged some X operations by a
maximization and then in the backward
then we have to produce a backward pass
and in the backward pass well we start
will essentially compose our decoded so
our predicted sequence by finding the
last label that maximizes the value in
our tail
and then following backward the trace of
the max operations so falling backward
the links that are going to correspond
to what were the arc max when I was
performing this maximization here so
more specifically let's look at the
pseudocode for this algorithm we first
initialize the value of my alpha star so
I'm going to start for the dynamic
program the Viterbi decoding algorithm
that is going to fill this alpha star
table as opposed to the alpha table and
notice that here we have a maximization
instead of lock some X operation or do a
maximization over what would be the
argument of Deluxe MX operation in the
computation of the log alpha table so I
initialize the first column of my alpha
star table by performing this
maximization and I also remember for
each value of y star sorry Y prime -
what was the actual value of y prime one
that was maximum is maximizing the sum
of the log factor so see here this is
the same thing as here so this is just
the Arg max of this maximization and
then much like in the log alpha table
I'll go from the first from K equals two
to the last till the last column and
then for each value of the label I'll
perform the similar similar computation
where I've replaced the lock some X by
the maximization and here I have unary
factor pairwise factor and the alpha
star so the value at my previous column
in my alpha star table and similarly
I'll remember what is the arc max I'll
put that into this other table which I'm
where I put the arrow to distinguish it
from the alpha star table and then
finally if I want to know what's the
probability of the most likely sequence
Y star so what's the maximum of Y star
of P of this should be Y star also well
it's just it just corresponds to taking
the maximum over this expression here
and so that's actually not exactly
taking I said they taking the max over
the last column but that's not exactly
true it's the max over the last column
plus the unary log factor for the last
position and then to perform decoding
that is to actually construct my
predicted sequence y star
I'll take D again the arc max of this
maximization here so the arc max of the
unary factor at the last position plus
the y at the alpha star for the last
column of my alpha star table so that's
going to be the predicted label for the
last position and then I'll go backwards
from the previous the last position till
the first and what I'll do is that Y
star K is just going to be what was the
arc max so we see the arrow here was
what was the arguments when I performed
the maximization for alpha star K
assuming that the value for y star K
plus 1 so for y prime K plus 1 is
actually Y star K plus 1 which is the
value Y star in my sequence that I
computed in a previous iteration so we
see that by initializing Y star capital
K here well I always have a value for
that so I'm going from right to left
using my previous Y star value to
construct my sorry or Matt I guess the
the value of Y star at the position to
the right to construct my prediction for
the position the current position K and
then going from right to left okay so
this is how I get this is an algorithm
but that is also that's you know a nice
complexity of that's polynomial in K and
capital K and capital C for computing
constructing a prediction and so
classifying a whole sequence of inputs
and producing a sequence of labels for
my sequence of inputs so the two types
of predictions this Viterbi decoding
approach and the other one that
maximizes the per position marginal are
two valid predictions to perform if we
really care about the some of
the sum of the per element the sum of
per element classification errors we
might want to prefer the first procedure
but if instead our prediction error if
the way we evaluate the performance of
our classification a sequence
classification system is different and
so for different systems like in speech
for instance we'd be more interested in
a phone error rate which is more
complicated than performing this Viterbi
decoding procedure is should be
preferred because then we're not
maximizing the sum of per position per
position errors